wow
to make way for the world's first
hydrogen bomb manufacturing complex the
atomic energy commission swallowed up
300 square miles of land in three
counties
an area four times the size of
washington dc whole towns were wiped off
the map forever these reactors have
malfunctioned and had the fuel rods have
melted down and this was kept covered up
by the dupont corporation and by the
department of energy and the atomic
energy commission before it
a number of accidents among the tanks
due to faulty design and human error
have allowed high level radiation to
escape to the surrounding soil
we also had another guy who worked there
as a mechanic worked there for 22 years
became sick because of exposure to
radiation the minute he became sick they
fired him no benefits or anything
no outside studies of contamination at
savannah river have been undertaken
secrecy protects the energy department
and its contractors from having to
explain how they do business well yeah
it's won awards all over the world it's
been the film festivals all over the
world got an academy award nomination in
this country won first place at a number
of film festivals it's been on
television a lot outside the u.s
oh we've tried to get it we offered it
free to public television in this
country and they've refused to run it i
think they're afraid of offending some
of the
nuclear industry who are some of the big
corporate sponsors of pbs
nuclear bombs nuclear power nuclear
waste
these are the subjects of a lot of
people's opinions and a documentary
which will
present to you right now on alternative
views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're real fortunate on alternative
views to have mark mori with us who
along with susan robinson made an
incredible documentary called building
bombs
it's about the savannah river plant
where they make you know they've got all
kinds of nice things there like
plutonium and they build all these
which they provide for the
nuclear weapons
which have been proliferated around the
world
but
mark
has kind of blown the whistle on the
organization the outfit and it's one of
these documentaries which i'm sure
you'll want to see we'll be able to see
portions of it on this alternative use
but we're going to find out the story
behind
building bombs and something about mark
mori
mark we understand that building bombs
was your first film that it took five
years to make and it got nominated for
an academy award what led you to make
the film in the first place
well i was living in atlanta georgia at
the time and a friend of mine was
telling me about this savannah river
plant which is over on the border
between georgia and south carolina
and i realized the place was a big
secret it was a big mystery here was
really the key nuclear weapons factory
in the united states
and i considered myself politically
knowledgeable started asking my friends
and nobody knew what it was about so i
thought it would be a good subject for a
film it hadn't gotten any attention in
the media there wasn't really any
discussion or there ever been any
accidents or spills there had been
accidents and spills but they had all
been kept secret
and this is part of what i discovered in
the course of making my film
[Music]
a number of accidents among the tanks
due to faulty design and human error
have allowed high-level radiation to
escape to the surrounding soil
over the years nine of the tanks the
older design tanks
have developed cracks
leaks developed in tank 16 just a few
months after it was put into service
it's a million gallon tank of the old
design not the modern design
the waste overflowed the five foot high
annulus pan into the soil surrounding
the tank it's in the water table
the time that we started to make the
film there was nothing in the press
about it people didn't even realize that
it was a bomb factory people thought it
was a nuclear power plant
did you have any trouble with the
government or with the company trying to
do the documentary i noticed you have
shots there beautiful shots inside the
place and talk to all kinds of people
you must have gotten a lot of
cooperation well
we didn't initially get any cooperation
initially they did not want to let a
film crew inside the place they said it
was top security it's higher security
there than a military base and they said
they had a policy of not letting film
crews in which i believed but they did
offer me some film footage
and
of what was going on inside there so
they promised me this and they promised
me this and i kept asking them for it
and they kept stalling and kept saying
well you know you can have this footage
and finally they sort of sheepishly
embarrassed said well you know we don't
really have very good film footage so
they kind of relented and let me bring
a film crew inside which i then did on
four subsequent occasions also
how safe has that plan been in the past
i noticed the government has shut it
down does that mean there have been
problems there well there's lots of
problems there but they have five
reactors there for making plutonium and
tritium which is the explosive part of a
nuclear weapon
and these reactors like i said a minute
ago these reactors have malfunctioned
and had the fuel rods have melted down
and this was kept covered up
by the dupont corporation and by the
department of energy and the atomic
energy commission before it
and it was only a couple of years ago
that this came out
no outside studies of contamination at
savannah river have been undertaken
secrecy protects the energy department
and its contractors from having to
explain how they do business
for 35 years dupont dumped toxic and
radioactive liquid wastes directly into
open pits at the rate of 200 000 gallons
a day
turtles swimming in these pits became
contaminated with strontium-90 one of
the most dangerous elements giving off
strong radiation
they were discovered at various
locations outside the plant including a
commercial hog farm
we have captured many of them and
brought them back on the plant site
we have fully apprised the owners of the
land where
the animals have been that this has been
the case
obviously the levels were high enough to
detect and to be of concern to us
because we are taking
action to to try to eliminate this this
problem
they have buried
radioactive waste in cardboard boxes
there for 30 years
even though the
radioactivity in each one of those
cardboard boxes was generally speaking
very low collectively
it was a large amount of contamination
the use of cardboard boxes
causes
collapse of the trenches and collapse of
the soil columns atop the trenches and
is ultimately going to cause the failure
of the barrel ground it has caused the
failure of every burial ground in the
united states
failure means radioactivity escapes
beyond the boundaries of the burial
ground
this only came out
that one of the people i feature in the
film it only came out when he exposed it
publicly when he blew the whistle all of
a sudden they decided this wasn't such a
good idea to bury radioactive waste in
cardboard boxes
good lord i mean anybody who knows
anything would
say that that was foolish well that's
what you would think but see the problem
with the savannah river plant and other
plants like it within the department of
energy complex is nobody was checking up
on what they were doing they were free
to do whatever they wanted it was under
the guise of national security and so
they
did anything and everything so does this
mean that nuclear weapons production is
not under the same constraints or
regulations as the nuclear energy
industry and we know what problems the
nuclear energy industry has had with
three mile island chernobyl and any
number of lesser uh problems in view of
that wouldn't you think that nuclear
weapons would be factories would be just
as stringently regulated well you've hit
a very important point the nuclear
weapons industry has been under no
regulation of any kind at all they were
not they were exempt from federal
pollution laws and it was only when some
of the states began to come in and be
concerned about these issues that the
federal government paid any attention to
it
so
it has been a serious problem because of
the national security
and an arrogance by the bomb makers they
have literally dumped radioactive waste
in the backyard of all these places
without regard for
what it would do to the environment is
this an effect of the cold war that the
veil of secrecy over nuclear weapons
production was justified according to
grounds of national security or
something because we're in a life and
death struggle with communism is that
the sort of rationale they give that's
precisely the rationale that because the
nuclear weapons production itself needed
to be kept secret that all aspects of
this were kept secret there was no
checking up by anybody in fact it was
the government was supposed to be using
corporate entities like dupont
westinghouse general electric to operate
these plants and telling them what to do
but what comes out in my film that you
can see is the corporations were
actually telling the government what to
do
the the
if a corporation like dupont did not
approve a report analyzing the problems
then the report would be killed this is
what we show in building bombs a
whistleblower that has a very
heart-wrenching story that goes through
a personal crisis and change of heart
when he realizes that he's being asked
to cover up
and endorse a huge radioactive waste
problem
and i wanted to see all of the the
stones uncovered and looked under
and after i'd been involved in it a few
months then i found out
that
only a very superficial report would be
acceptable in fact the more superficial
the better
department of energy managers signed the
report and sent it to dupont
lawless expected some action to be taken
as a result of his findings
the report had a profound effect
our impact on dewpoint and dewpoint
called the department of energy and had
the report recalled lawless was given
the report back and asked to rewrite it
he did adding new evidence each month
it was rejected again
and again
and again
after two years management asked him to
stop working on it the report was killed
so what the cold war has meant while we
were focused on the soviet union and
while we thought that the problem was
building weapons to defend ourselves we
were being poisoned by our own
government is essentially what happened
and why were the corporations concerned
to kill some of these reports because
they were making big profits from it
because they didn't want to be
criticized or what were there well it
wasn't so much that they were making big
profits dupont in in the case of the
savannah river plant was technically not
making profit but they wanted to avoid
liability they did not want to be stuck
after they dumped millions of gallons of
radioactive
they didn't want to clean it up they
didn't want to clean it up they didn't
want the liability of the sicknesses
that would cause and that sort of thing
i think there are some other
fascinating aspects about your
documentary one is that
this
whole building of the plant itself first
of all it came in and destroyed how many
acres or how many square miles 300
square miles of south carolina six towns
were just wiped off the map and taken
over by the government in order to build
the savannah river plan
to make way for the world's first
hydrogen bomb manufacturing complex the
atomic energy commission swallowed up
300 square miles of land in three
counties
an area four times the size of
washington dc
whole towns were wiped off the map
forever
6 000 people from 1500 different
families had to move
and in fact a couple of people who
resisted this were put in mental
institutions the kind of thing we're
told happens only in the soviet union
and then there was this whole new
economic and social structure that was
come in and dumped down right in the
middle of it
right it became this was aiken south
carolina we're talking about it became
the company town of the bomb plant
14 000 people have jobs at the savannah
river plant today that wouldn't have
them if it were not for the savannah
river plan and then not just common
ordinary labor and jobs their jobs high
technology jobs
the influx of this many phds and masters
of science and other people that have
come into the area
has had a tremendous
influence on this city and this area and
the state of south carolina
and it's a typical company town kind of
situation it's a rural southern area
they are economically dependent on this
place these are the highest paying jobs
in the state of south carolina a floor
sweeper there starts at 15 an hour
so
they their only alternative is to work
in a textile mill for five dollars an
hour or work in a cotton field
so you can and and the press there the
newspapers controlled by
the plant the former editor of the plant
newspaper is editor of the town
newspaper so they only got one side of
the story but when i showed building
bombs there
my film oh yeah
yeah it got a very positive response
from people i mean they came in to the
film hostile they had been told
that this film was threatening their
jobs and in fact
the employer at the plant which later
became westinghouse encouraged people to
go out and see the film because i think
they were saying them you have to oppose
this and and and
protect your job but people saw their
own kind in the film talking their own
language and it rang true with them so
we got a very positive response from
even the people that work at the plant
about the film how did you get people
that were former employees or even
current employees to talk had there been
a lot of disease a lot of radiation
sicknesses or did people just have a
pang of conscience that led them to
speak out well in a couple of cases it
was people's that had gone through a
change one was a physicist that had
worked at the place for 30 years and
really had retired and once he retired
then he
felt the need he hadn't been happy with
what he had been doing there and he felt
the need to speak out he realized that
during his years at the plant the
country's stockpile had grown to greater
than 30 000 of the bombs dropped on
nagasaki
it seemed rather obscene
i just could not conceive of our need
for that many weapons it filled me with
a sense of revulsion i
went away and felt that i had to do some
thinking about
what i'd seen and what i was involved in
we had an engineer who was in charge of
all the low-level radioactive waste
management at the plant who like i
mentioned a minute ago once he began to
be directly involved in the cover-up he
couldn't live with himself quit his job
became a whistleblower took a job for
one-third of his former salary because
he thought the threat of radiation in
the environment was so great to people
that he had to sound that alarm we also
had another guy who worked there as a
mechanic worked there for 22 years
became sick because of exposure to
radiation he was diagnosed as having
polycythemia vera
this rare blood disease is seen in
people who live at high altitudes
and those exposed to radiation
the people there
workers i mean we didn't think there was
anything wrong with you couldn't see it
in that now so we just thought you could
eat the dying stuff it wouldn't hurt you
at all so
we didn't pay too much attention we had
somebody supposed to be checking us out
and checking with it
we depended on them to do their job the
same that we were doing hours as a
mechanic
four years after leaving the savannah
river plant george couch tested positive
for tritium in his blood
the minute he became sick they fired him
no benefits or anything even after 22
years
how safe actually is the plant itself
now the government shut it down a while
back well the government shut it down
because they cannot safely operate the
reactors even they even admitted that
and they recently tried to restart the k
reactor they're one of the five big
reactors
after spending several billion dollars
trying to refurbish this 40 year old
reactor and get it to operate
uh even then it wouldn't operate
properly they ended up spilling
radioactive water into the savannah
river for 100 miles downstream all the
communities had to shut off their water
intakes so that people wouldn't have
radioactive water running out of their
faucets this was exposed in the new york
times wasn't it was it a couple years
ago there were some front page articles
on this that sort of uncovered the veil
of uh secrecy did you have anything to
do with that were you connected to those
reporters
anyway i take it you were making your
film by then right these articles came
out in in the new york times in late
1988 we had actually started making our
film in 1984
and for most of that period were unaware
of
anybody else trying to do this story
which i thought was incredible that all
the mainstream media was around nobody's
digging into this situation and just
about the time we were finishing our
film articles began to come out in the
new york times exposing some of these
things so actually it really helped
exposing everything that all of our
material began to hit at the same time
how safe is the savannah river
project and the reactors compared to
chernobyl well i think they're a little
safer as long as they keep them shut
down
but
well the one physicist we have in the
film
who helped design the reactors at
savannah river plant he calls it a
chernobyl accident waiting to happen
in the wake of the chernobyl disaster
concern across the united states arose
over the energy department's aging
weapons facilities
once widely touted as an economic boon
the savannah river plant's presence was
openly debated
it was reported that the energy
department was routinely releasing large
amounts of airborne radioactive gases
into the atmosphere
and covering up serious reactor
accidents including incidents of fuel
rods melting during operations
these things have no containment domes
these reactors could not operate for a
single day if they had to come under
the
regulations that commercial power
reactors are subject to these reactors
have no containment domes if there's an
explosion it will spew radiation all
over the countryside which did not
happen in three mile island because it
has a containment dome so in a sense
there's some aspects of these reactors
that are even less safe than chernobyl
hasn't there been any attempt by
congress since the new york times
articles in your film to regulate the
production of nuclear weapons i mean
this seems just an unbelievable scandal
and i would think there'd be public
pressure just simply to pass some laws
to regulate production of nuclear
anything be it energy or weapons well
there has been some attempts in congress
to do some things i think one thing that
happened was some congressmen put their
faith in admiral watkins the secretary
the new secretary of energy
and
i think he's they've become disappointed
in him because they've seen even though
he stated that he was trying to change
the culture department of energy
basically things have not really changed
and
so some brave congressmen and senators
have tried to do something but really
they it's such a humongous problem they
haven't even been able to get a hold of
it i mean at the end of the cold war we
don't need any more nuclear weapons i've
read that there's a scandal that we have
twice as many nuclear weapons now as
could conceivably ever be used and so
there's obviously no need to produce any
more nuclear weapons for the next
hundred generations so it seems like
it's a logical process just to wind down
nuclear weapons
production well one of the things i
found is there's nothing logical about
the nuclear weapons industry
from the way they dealt with waste the
massive numbers of nuclear weapons they
produced now they want to restart these
old decrepit worn out 40 year old
reactors to keep producing nuclear
weapons
for another 10 or 20 years and they are
trying to build new reactors so they can
keep producing plutonium and tritium and
nuclear weapons well past the middle of
the 21st century i mean
there's no conception that things have
really changed
that's that's a scandal
how has your
film
been received i noticed new york times
that very glowing reports on it and
reviews
where else has it shown has it won
awards anywhere well yeah it's won
awards all over the world it's been to
film festivals all over the world got an
academy award nomination in this country
won first place at a number of film
festivals it's been on television a lot
outside the us
oh we've tried to get it we offered it
free to public television in this
country and they've refused to run it i
think they're afraid of offending some
of the
nuclear industry who are some of the big
corporate sponsors of pbs
but um
so we have actually successfully now
gotten it around in some theaters so i
would suggest people can watch and see
if it shows up in a local theater in
their area
and
hopefully because of that we'll be able
to get it into some video stores also
what were the reasons that pbs gave you
the reason that the reason that the pbs
told me that
they refused to run building bombs was
it fails to give adequate voice to the
proponents of nuclear arms
oh for heaven's sake will you have
people all throughout who are
pro-savannah river project pro-nuke
well not only that the pro-nuclear
people have had dominated the media for
the last 40 years absolutely i mean it's
not like
you know
there's been uh the the point of view
that is expressed in my film has come
out very much because it hasn't so i
that's why it's a pretty thinly veiled
over the real reason which is that these
dupont westinghouse
ge these big corporations whose logos
you see on pbs are really what they're
afraid of well this also is totally
speechless because it fails to
understand the very nature of
documentary film which is not like a
network news production where you're
supposed to show both sides of the story
in fact there's been a pbs series called
point of view that showed documentaries
that took a very specific point of view
and over the past few years whenever
there's been documentaries on pbs that
are too much to the left they always
have a discussion after with people
representing the other point of view
although i've never seen them do this
when there's a conservative documentary
or show that they give the other point
of view so that just doesn't hold any
water
in fact how do you
perceive documentary
film what's your notion of the
documentary and how do you conceive your
own work as a documentary filmmaker well
you know making documentaries is very
difficult it takes a a passion and a
commitment
and so i think any documentaries that
are
receive notoriety are probably worth
seeing just because of the number of
obstacles that have to be overcome in
making them one i mean there's no money
in making them so it just represents a
passion and a commitment and it allows
people to look in on a world that maybe
they wouldn't otherwise see so
so while
officially documentaries are ignored a
lot i think
you know it behooves people to seek them
out and what do you see the role of your
film doing as exposing and revealing or
articulating your own point of view what
was your own
sort of sense of what you were doing
well my sense of what i was doing was in
a sense was telling a good story an
entertaining story but at the end of it
you know you really had to sit up and
think and say you know there's something
i can do about this there's something i
should do about this there's something
going on here that i need to find out
more about so that's was my objective
what about
nationwide and even worldwide there are
savannah river type projects
all around are they having the same
problems at folks in aitkin south
carolina well yes all the department of
energy facilities are shut down at this
point rocky flats in colorado
hanford up in washington for an alden
ohio they've all got the same problems
all these plants are 40 or 50 years old
they're worn out and the department of
energy doesn't really want to face up to
the fact that they should just be shut
down permanently and and um you know
there's these same problems in the
soviet union and in fact as bad as the
problems are here they're worse in the
soviet union with their bomb factories
over there so it's a perfect time
worldwide simply to shut down nuclear
weapon production it seems that there's
more than enough nuclear weapons to blow
up the world many times the cold war is
supposedly over so wouldn't this be the
time really to promote the shutting down
of nuclear weapons production on a
worldwide scale well i think that's
certainly true and films like building
bombs and deadly dissection are very
timely for that reason i think and
we need to face up to the fact that this
we don't need any more nuclear weapons
and we need to find a problem with the
nuclear waste there is we've had nuclear
waste now for 50 years
yet we have not found any solution to it
and there's a lot of it out there
let's take a look back at some of the
previous alternative use programs in
which people express their opinions
about nuclear power first we'll have dr
helen caldecott a pediatrician who's the
author of nuclear madness
followed by randy king who survived a
three-mile island disaster
an article last week in business week
a very conservative business magazine
saying that nuclear power is
economically almost dead but very sick
and they don't print those and wall
street journal's been saying this too so
the fact is that nuclear power is
heavily subsidized by the government and
what people may not know is that
to enrich uranium and that's what you
put in a nuclear reactor it's like
putting wood in a fire you put uranium
in a reactor it's extremely energy
consuming and uranium enrichment alone
in this country uses three percent of
all the electricity generated so you
have to take that off the amount of
electricity generated to get a good
figure an accurate figure
each nuclear reactor only lasts about 15
to 30 years and then they become so
radioactive that you can't send people
in them to operate them because they'll
be so irradiated they could get cancer
or have deformed children so then they
have to either take them apart by remote
control and bury the parts somewhere for
a long time isolated from the
environment or cover them up them up
with half a mile of concrete and earth
for half a million years and nobody must
dig into them because they're terribly
dangerous
so that's called decommissioning that's
not taken into the cost of electricity
and massive amounts of very poisonous
radioactive waste are produced in
reactors the government has the faintest
idea what to do with it there's just
been a national
survey done by the department of energy
asking the public what they should do
with the nuclear waste and they don't
know and it has to be stored from the
environment for one million years
and a recent survey survey by the epa
using mit geologists says that whatever
they put this waste in it so hot and
radioactive be it glass ceramics metal
or whatever will start to disintegrate
within 10 years
and it has to be isolated for 1 million
years now the cost of this has never
been considered in the cost of
electricity from nuclear power well in
the morning march 28 1979
through a combination of technical
errors and human errors the worst
commercial nuclear accident in the
history of the nuclear power industry
developed
that accident brought the core of unit
two reactor to within a half an hour of
melting down
and what would have happened had it
melted down if it would have melted down
it would have probably have wiped out
the entire eastern seaboard from
washington dc to philadelphia to new
york city my god
how is that possible i mean what would
have happened well if the core would
have melted down it would have melted
through the bottom of the containment
building which was a four foot thick
concrete
structure and hit the water table
beneath the island and exploded in
radioactive steam the radioactive steam
would have been dispersed throughout the
entire eastern seaboard at the time of
the accident there were seven radiation
monitoring devices placed around the
plant only two of those were operational
the monitoring devices that were on the
stacks of the containment building at
the time of the accident had a top
reading of a thousand milligrams they
were off scale for better than three
three days after the accident began
so in effect we really don't know
exactly how much radiation we have
received
i do know that in the nine months after
the accident
the infant mortality rate
miscarriages and hypothyroid diseases
amongst young children went up tenfold
of human beings and human beings i've
seen some pictures in the village voice
of animals a lot of miscarriages or
strange creatures that were born from
animals
deformities of certain sorts have you
seen any of these and was this a
widespread phenomenon
in the areas that the plume passed over
yes and i have seen some of those
animals such as
siamese cows being born and cows with
three legs
a cow with an eye in the middle of its
forehead
a cat with no bones in the back of its
body things of that nature it was very
sad
one specific specific thing where the
plume passed over
it was about an acre wide area and it
hit some trees and some of the trees had
leaves on one side and their trees or no
leaves on the other side so there's no
question that a lot of radioactivity was
released from three mile island and it's
had lethal effects yes well they've been
radioactivity uh
placed into the water of the susquehanna
river right
during the time of the accident two
thousand gallons were released into the
river
they found radioactive rat droppings
in the containment building last year
they quickly said that there was no
danger to the public safety
and that none of the rats had left the
island
we asked how do they know none of the
rats have left the island do they take
roll call every morning
that pretty much
explains
how gpu deals with the general public
at the time of the accident general
public utilities had 300 million dollars
in insurance money
and they predicted that cleanup process
would take 40 million dollars and six
months
six months later it was hundred million
dollars
in five years
several months ago it was one and a half
billion dollars in eighteen to twenty
years
they have no money
to clean up three island now the federal
government says it will not give them
any money to clean it up so now the rate
payers are being saddled with it their
rates have gone up some 70 percent
we feel that the utility in the nuclear
industry and nuclear utilities around
the country
and the federal government either
through funding or through legislation
requiring the nuclear industry to pay
for the cleanup is what should happen
harrisburg and hiroshima are sister
cities
after the disaster of three mile island
dr helen caldecott
returned with a program called medical
implications of nuclear power
that's what the nuclear industry have
called for years the melt through to
china syndrome and that's why the movie
was called the china syndrome
and when that happens there'll be a huge
steam explosion which will rupture the
containment vessel and release the
radiation inside and there's as much
radiation in these reactors as that
released by a thousand hiroshima type
bombs
that's why the nrc officials were
sweating on national television
they should have ordered evacuation
because when you read the government
documents i've just written a paper on
this
if there was a meltdown it would totally
and permanently devastate an area the
size of pennsylvania
but you have to keep it quiet
remember if you read the tapes henry
who's the head of the nrc said
is there a law
for freedom of the press if there is i'm
against it
and all through the tapes are talking
about how to keep this quiet
we won't evacuate yet because it would
be bad publicity for the nuclear
industry
what has to happen for the people of the
world to wake up
these are huge death machines it would
be a catastrophe the likes of which the
world has never seen before worse than
hiroshima worse
i'd really like to hear a bit more about
the radiation leakage at the savannah
river nuclear plant
they make all of our weapons grade pluto
plutonium there you might realize
and as you may have heard people from
seven south carolina towns ringing the
plant have contracted a rare blood
disease associated with exposure to
radiation
a spokesman for the energy department
said that they had no knowledge of these
reported cases
but they had nothing to do with the plan
of course
some seven hundred thousand people live
within sixty miles of the savannah site
which is owned by
guess who the energy department
and run by our big buddy dupont
this could be the start of something big
y'all stay tuned
the savannah plant surely has
state-of-the-art radiation shielding
to protect surrounding citizens
are we now to understand that all of our
safety precautions
and all of our nukes aren't quite as
adequate as we thought
should we maybe rethink or recalculate
this whole thing
i'm just curious
i'm also curious about these love canal
home site that the environmental
protection agency says are once again
inhabitable
did all that poison really just up and
go away
you see lately i've gotten this funny
way of looking at government agencies i
don't trust them
isn't that terrible
but i do think we could resolve this
whole matter of agency credibility with
one easy step
the government that's we the people
owns the land and love canal right
well let's throw up a few prefabs there
and outfit them with window units
heaters and water coolers and the like
then we can move and gorsuch and the epa
to their new love canal headquarters
they can live in the abandoned houses
there of course
and if they're all still healthy after a
couple of years we'll know it's safe to
build condos there and put them on the
market
in savannah until we get quonset huts
set up the energy department can stay at
the nearest holiday inn
there's an old saying in the military a
good leader won't ask a man to do
anything that he wouldn't do himself
now i can get behind that
as a matter of fact
for my own spiritual well-being this is
definitely one of those times that i'd
say
you first fearless leader
next on alternative views
we're going to
take a look back at a
program we did with author harvey
wasserman who wrote killing our own
about the dangers of nuclear power
here are some of his comments we still
don't know how much radiation escaped
all the major
methods of measuring radioactive
emissions during the three-mile island
accident completely broke down uranium
miners have a five times normal lung
cancer rate because of the ingestion of
radon gas there are literally billions
of tons
of
these
highly radioactive tailings scattered
all through the west
and uh
it it significantly alters the
background levels of radiation in the
world he recently published some papers
calculating the health impacts of the
chernobyl accident and his basic uh
assessment is that given the amount of
radiation that escaped there will be 900
000 additional cancer human cancer cases
around the world over the next 30 years
half of them fatal the long time ago the
aec atomic energy commission conceded
that at a major meltdown you would
depopulate you'd have to de-permanently
depopulate an area the size of
pennsylvania
the united states alone is armed with 25
000 nuclear warheads
17 facilities across the country are
involved in the research design testing
and production of nuclear bombs
these facilities have accumulated
approximately 300 million cubic feet of
radioactive waste
cleanup of these sites where possible
could cost 100 million
at hanford rocky flats savannah river
and other weapons making sites citizens
are suffering from doe negligence and
secrecy
in recent months the department of
energy has at least been trying to clean
house and is now admitting its own gross
mismanagement
states are closing their borders to hot
trash as they come to grips with a
nuclear waste dilemma
in the southeastern plains of new mexico
whip
or the waste isolation pilot project
nears completion after 10 years
construction
millions of years ago the ocean left
bass salt deposits here
100 acres of connected caves have been
carved into these ancient salt beds one
half mile underground
here military nuclear waste is destined
to be sealed away for a minimum of ten
thousand years
nuclear waste will be traveling through
28 states perhaps through your
neighborhood on its way to whip
in communities along the nuclear
corridor
concern is growing the department of
energy predicts that there'll be 1450
shipments a year
through new mexico
i-25 will receive a thousand shipments a
year which will be about three shipments
a day past las vegas
other
wastes will be coming from south
carolina and from tennessee
ohio and illinois on i-40
one of my major concerns is that
there'll be an accident the city of
roswell has passed an ordinance saying
that the trucks will not be able to come
through roswell except between midnight
and 6 a.m
doe is already challenging that
ordinance saying that that ordinance
won't be enforced what if one of those
trucks come by
and
makes a you know hits the bridge and one
of those containers go into the river
it's not going to affect me it's going
to affect hundreds and thousands and
millions of people down down river
because it's going to contaminate the
water it won't be usable anymore the
fish won't be edible anymore
i have a military background i have a
weapons background i've worked in the
weapons industry
[Music]
i think they always wanted us to think
they being the government
that we have
no voice no control nothing we can do
trust us we're your federal government
believe in us it's what they told the
people in hanford
that's what they told the people in
savannah river fernault they're telling
us that new mexico
not acceptable again
not acceptable well there's been 170
radioactive
accidents across the country 34 of those
have happened in new mexico we do have
some rationale because
we've been shipping this waste
from rocky flats in colorado up to idaho
for you know
a very long period of time 25 years or
more
and we have had accidents but there has
never been a release
and there has never been a
release of radiation from a type b
container
it never will be that with all the
transportation of all these
high-level waste and trans-ceramic waste
we may be ending up with
chernobyl's along the nuclear highways
because if there's any ever any spill of
plutonium
uh
of a significant degree it'll be so
devastating that'll it'll render large
parts of this country uninhabitable
the documentary the whip trail was
produced by penelope place
now let's turn our attention to the
alternative press
and take a look at some news stories
which the regular media don't give to
you
we've all heard the term apple polishers
and we've heard the term apple for the
teacher you know a child gets an apple
and he polishes up an apple polisher
that was another term that we hear all
the time somebody
gets and polishes up an apple real nice
and makes it shine then they go give it
to the teacher
well
[Music]
you got to be
wary
of waxed apples and veggies now because
that veggie the veggies and the gloss
may have more than you bargained for
maybe even a little bit of cancer
but there are
products ranging from relatively
non-toxic beeswax and paraffin to more
toxic vinyl chloride polymers or pcbs
which companies put on
these products
then several fungicides can be added to
the waxes
that's what makes them deadly
some of them are known
for their potential to cause cancer and
birth defects
and the epa considers
opp which is orthophenyl
whatever
it's placing it on its list of the most
toxic inerts
a recent natural academy of scientists
report says that 90 percent of the
fungicides
that they've tested are carcinogenic and
these waxes the problem with the waxes
is they cannot be washed off
effectively
even with vinegar and a detergent
now
does the government look out out for us
despite a january 1987 finding
that the epa was arbitrary and
capricious
and allowing fruit treated with 1984
banned
carcinogen ethylene dibromide or edb
to be imported into the united states
what did the circuit court of appeals do
well it decided to go ahead and allow
edb to be used
on mangoes
through
september of 1987.
this is an old article as you can see
but you better watch out
when you start looking at that nice
shiny waxy apple or
other types of fruits or vegetables
you better go to your health food store
and get you some organic food folks
according to a broadcast on radio new
zealand the greenpeace yacht vega is
maintaining a vigil and 125
000 square mile missile impact zone
north of the marshall islands despite
warnings to stay out of the impact zone
by the u.s military united states
intercontinental missiles are expected
to be test fired into the area from
california at any time
greenpeace says that it's worried about
the cumulative effects on the ozone
layer from such missile tests that have
been conducted in the marshall islands
since the 1960s and to protest these
missile tests they have their yacht
floating around in the waters near these
islands to try to prevent the missiles
from being fired so this is really
putting your life on the line for your
philosophy
you better check to see what you got
underneath your arms
maybe something that'll
it'll chip paint on cars
it seems that workers in chrysler
corporation's jeep plant according to
the associated press
have been asked to stop using
antiperspirants because they leave
craters on the paint of vehicles and
causes thousands of dollars of damage it
seems these antiperspirants contain
aluminum
chlorine silicon
and when it flakes off
the arms of armpits of the workers it
gets down onto the cars
and
if the flakes aren't removed before a
car is painted the paint flows away and
causes small craters
and at one point according to the
associated press nearly every vehicle
coming off the paint line had been
cratered
so you better check to see what you're
putting underneath your arms
there's an article by common cause
magazine of march
and april of 1990 that indicate that
three of the most powerful men in the
world have a little oil venture at on
the side that they share a long-standing
financial interest in a houston-based
tank barge business that's one of the
major polluters in the united states
these three men with their barge
happened to be george bush secretary of
commerce robert mossbacker and secretary
of state james baker this is curious
common cause says because the bush
administration has proclaimed itself the
environmental presidency the tank barge
industry is a major polluter of u.s
waterways and the company that manages
the bush mossbacker baker barges is one
of the largest tank barge companies in
the united states
collectively its barges which carry
petroleum products has spilled upwards
of 200 times since 1980 government
documents show
the ultimate parent company of this bush
mossbacker baker barges is the hollywood
holding company an umbrella corporation
that splintered for tax purposes and to
make sure these guys don't get sued for
pollution but it's basically
controlled by a bunch of houston
interests of which mossbacker and bush
and baker are big players in 1978
mossbacker bought a lot of this company
and his buddy george bush also bought
into this to the tune of fifty thousand
dollars and james baker also invested
fifty thousand dollars in the hollywood
holding company later in 1979 and 80
baker invested at least 125 000 more in
hollywood partnerships and mossbacker
made big investments throughout the
1980s
well this is the only
actual economic holding that bush put on
his income taxes in 1988 all of the rest
of his economic holdings were put in a
blind trust which meant that he didn't
know if they were sold if new ones were
bought he didn't supposedly know what
his financial holdings were but he knew
he had hollywood holdings simply because
it was so lucrative the bush has reaped
130 thousand dollars from his original
investment in the bank
in the tank barge partnership and bush
continues to reap twenty thousand
dollars a year for the foreseeable
future off of this investment that again
is one of the biggest polluters in the
united states it should be said in
conclusion though that in 1989 after the
exxon valdez spiel spill in which oil
pollution became a big issue with media
focus finally bush decided to put his
hollywood holding
interest in a blind trust so he wouldn't
be accused of having
economic interest in an industry that
was a big polluter
bush's hypocrisy knows no bounds he
calls himself the environmental
president and he himself has a big
holdings in a company that's one of the
biggest polluters in the country
it's a bit important to know a little
bit about the people who are trying to
get the presidential nominations for
both democratic and the republican
parties there are some things about
bill clinton for instance that haven't
been in the mainstream media
spotlight on march 16 1992 had an
article about the
big sugar daddy behind
clinton his name is jackson stevens
he's the head man and stevens
incorporated little rock arkansas
investment firm one of the largest
investment banks in the country
he's a bit of a reclusive figure who's
one of the men
involved in the starting up of bcci
according to the spotlight
and he is financing
bill
clinton he also did this before
he arranged for
the arkansas governor to have a two
million dollar line of credit to keep
his campaign rolling for governor
previously however
as in true uh single party fashion you
know we always say we have a single
party system just split into two halves
and uh john stockwell calls it the a
team the republicans and the b team the
democrats but it's all the same team but
anyway
oh jackson stevens is a big buddy of
george bush as well
uh stephen's wife marianne was the 1988
co-chairperson for the bush for
president dr
and stevens himself donated a hundred
thousand dollars to team 100 which is a
republican group that collected big
bucks for bush's
big push for the white house
and then
in 1991
low and behold stevens comes up with
another 100
000 to bush in may
there's another thing about clinton
which nobody has brought out yet and
that is that he is a member of the
highly secret and very elite bilderberg
organization
a very
secret group of international
power brokers
dominated or at least a little bit of
shared power perhaps now by david
rockefeller and the people who are
invited to build a burger or meetings
are
very carefully screened and so they
generally run through the bilderbergers
or trilateral commission or the council
on foreign relations
the people whom they are wanting to
support later to run for
president
and frequently vice president the united
states
so we do have
bill clinton who's a bilderberger and
george bush who's a former member of the
trilateral commission so it's all a
little cozy group there and don't
remember don't forget uh big daddy buck
stevens who is supporting them both with
his money
[Music]
i don't think we as a nation or as a
society or as a world can any longer
afford to take
nice neat little problems package them
up and assign them to bureaucracies and
and expect those problems to be solved
we just cannot do that we have to
participate in this ourselves we have to
stay involved
and if we can't stay involved maybe we
shouldn't get into them
we don't know we've got it we don't know
what to do with it that's the thing
if we've got it and don't know what to
do why should we need more
well to find out some way of doing
something with it or getting rid of it
before we start making more
for another stockpile
brings up the question why do we
continue to produce these things why do
we
continue to
put our people in jeopardy just even by
things of this kind where we're
transporting them through cities and
over highways and into the very lives of
the
populous
perhaps
i can't
throw the first stone again i'm not
without sin
i think that i could wish that my life
had run entirely different
[Music]
i'm just grateful that i've lived long
enough to have an opportunity to
view things differently though turn my
thinking around and
recognize what's going on or
i hope that my view is
freer the astigmatism that i once had
if i felt personally humiliated because
i did not speak out at a very critical a
very pivotal time
and and so i took that humiliation back
with me to the savannah river plant
and slowly began to confront myself and
to resolve the issues within myself and
to know what i had to do and to go
forward from that point on
it's a very slow process but it's a very
difficult process for most people at
least it was for me
to confront yourself and to come to
terms with it and then finally
start doing what you think is right
and then the more that you do it the
easier it becomes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
frequently hear from viewers who request
a list of news publications which we use
on alternative views and also a reading
list for u.s power structure in the mass
media if you would like to have these
send a stamped self-addressed envelope
to the alternative information network
p o box 7279
austin texas 787 13 you must send a
self-addressed stamped envelope
we would like to thank
the campaign for global security
particularly jim ellinger and jeff
sibley for facilitating our program
today
and special thanks to mark moray who let
us use his wonderful documentary or
sections of it building bombs
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
po box 7279
austin texas
78713
bye